Welcome back, master and mistress!
I kept you waiting.
Hello!
Welcome to the final installment of Peace Walker.
I love this game.
I'm sad.
Oh my gosh.
I was looking for my lip balm.
My lip butter.
I was looking for my lip butter this entire time that the loading screen was happening.
And then I look over and it's right there.
Butter up those lips.
Better than a pooper.
Yay!
I wish... I kind of want to watch... Wait, if I click back...
I want to watch the intro video again.
I want to watch it one more time.
Classic.
One more time.
The intro one last time.
We just have to wait for it to do it's thing.
I'm eating on a cough drop right now.
Anyways.
Nevermind.
No anyways.
Anyways, let's start the video!
How are you today, Mint?
I'm good!
How are you?
That's what I was going to say.
I was going to say, how was your weekend?
I want to make sure that the volume is not going to blow us away.
Guys, I'm here!
I'm here!
It's a doorknob.
That's my girl!
Pacific Ocean, I love you!
Alberto!
Chico!
Cecile!
Oh my gosh, we did that!
We fought that!
Why are they out of order?
That thing is such a mess looking.
Huey, what were you thinking?
The thing is such a mess.
Oh my gosh, it's such a good intro.
With the peace signs and everything.
So good!
A mint cafe suddenly appeared in my area.
But it's not open because the doorknob is missing.
Wow, you better go catch it!
Freaky normal mint.
YAY!
Blood hole year!
Thanks!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Who do I hate more?
Huey or Naomi?
Naomi.
I actually hate Naomi.
Huey is fun to hate.
Naomi, I actually hate her.
There is not a single character that I actually hate besides Naomi.
Everyone else I'm just like, oh I hate them!
Because it's silly.
But Naomi is actually just like pure unadulterated hatred.
Unadulterated.
Anyway, for those who don't know.
I did a member stream.
I did, I did, I did.
Oh my gosh, I saw Touhou 20.
What was it?
Fossilized something something?
Yeah, and Jojo part 7.
Actually, Steel Ball Run is the only Jojo that I know.
Yeah!
Funny.
Back to your regularly scheduled Peace Walker stream.
But yeah, I did a member stream.
Where I did some missions.
I did some missions so that we can finish today.
Because look, we're already on Zadornov mission.
So for those who don't know.
What the?
What do you mean please reconnect controller?
Are you dying?
One moment please.
I'm getting my cable.
I have it right here.
Just gotta unzip it.
For those who don't know, Zadornov escapes.
You get him in jail, in your little jail.
And he escapes.
Not 1, not 2, not 3, not 4.
Not even 5 times.
He will just keep...
Leaving for like 7 whole missions.
But...
Because he's a little rascal.
Thank you for the red.
Yeah, someone keeps turning Zadornov.
Exactly.
So we're gonna go find this guy again.
It's actually quite funny how you find him.
Because he's just...
Again.
Okay.
Yeah, so we're gonna...
So for today, just before we start this too.
I want to obviously...
Complete the main ops.
Which we don't have so many left.
I believe we only have...
After this we'll have 3.
6, 7 and then the final boss.
And then there's a few side ops that I want to do.
Such as...
The monster hunter.
And...
It's your birthday!
Coa Coffee, happy birthday!
Wait,
hold on.
I'm gonna go back actually.
Because I also want to do these AI weapon battles.
So that we can unlock...
A certain date.
Obviously we've done the date with Paz.
I did that last time.
But we have some other fun ones.
Like the Booyan mission and...
This one I unlocked because I really wanted to do this one!
The ghost photography!
Yes.
Very excited.
And...
So...
Cut, cut, cut.
So let's do Zadornov.
We're just gonna jump right into it.
I do have some...
I do have some stuff I gotta do tonight.
So I don't think today's stream will be super duper long.
I might be eating my words.
But...
Yes.
We're just gonna...
Finish it up baby.
Join!
I'm still in Tuxedo Snake.
What if I forgot all my stuff?
That would be so funny.
Stealth.
We gotta go find Zadornov.
We gotta go find that guy.
We got our Fultons.
Are you ready?
Yeah!
You made it!
You made it.
Stealth.
I'm just gonna start.
Is that ok?
You have a countdown now.
Hurry.
Hello Mindo.
Hello!
I think next...
Here, I'll let you have more time.
I think next week too, I'll do Ground Zeroes.
Immediately after this game.
So that we can at least...
Cause that'll just be one stream.
And then...
Might wait a little bit before starting 5.
A little bit.
For 5, I'm definitely playing with mods.
I'm just gonna warn you guys.
In advance.
Yeah, Ground Zeroes is gonna be...
No spoilers everybody.
But...
Yeah.
There are mods in B?
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
There's mods.
One of them, which is really great is...
Every soldier can be S rank.
I just finished Beast Walker trying to catch up and those damn onion ninjas attacked again.
Solid Snake.
Alright, let's go find Zadornov.
Hello!
Ok.
What are you doing?
This guy will fall asleep.
No you didn't.
There we go.
Uh oh, wait.
You think he's gonna see anything?
Oh, uh oh.
I got him.
I got him, no worries.
We're not in an alert.
How many model swaps are you planning to use?
Probably...
Not a lot.
Probably not actually a lot.
I'm gonna take this guy.
Um, I don't know exactly what mods I'm gonna get just yet.
You don't think, oh wait.
He's probably not in this area, no?
Let's keep going.
You guys will know when you see him, maybe.
Are you one of the model swaps?
Ocelot is quiet, it's so funny.
You have to hear laughter?
Wait, you can hear Zadornov laughing?
I haven't heard him laughing before.
What?
Oh, what the...
Oh, nice shot!
Oh dang, I'm gonna get this guy in the butt.
Uh oh, wait.
No!
Wait, who?
Where?
How?
Wait, how did they see?
Where is he anyway?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I'm reloading.
What did we do wrong?
What is it?
Oh, there is nothing over here.
Oh!
Sorry, that was me.
That was definitely me.
Sorry.
He's
fine.
Don't worry about it.
Let's keep going.
Let's ignore those guys.
I feel like he's not gonna be here either too, right?
I feel.
How did you get spotted?
I'm just...
I'm just not sneaky enough.
I don't remember where he is here, I'll be honest.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna become a box.
Snake in.
Wait.
Oh, how the hell did you get in there so fast?
What the?
Wait.
Draw.
Um, am I too... am I too...
Ok, nevermind.
I'm not gonna do it.
I give up.
That guy got in there so fast.
Ok, I'll take the...
Yeah, there we go.
Ok.
And get this guy.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Did we get him?
Ok, you got him.
Let's go.
Oh, there is another guy.
Ah!
I tried to hold him up!
What happened?
Why?
Oh my gosh, where did that guy come from?
Yeah, take him down.
What you got?
Did we look around this area?
I don't know why I'm just like deciding that he's so far away.
You know?
I'm just... maybe... Oh, is he up here?
Let's check.
You're so right.
We're investigating the area.
There is always stuff up here though.
That's good to take, I suppose.
Oh no!
Are you ok?
Wait, why is the...
Why does it say we're in alert mode?
You see that?
Are you ok?
He's like, are you ok?
You're
gonna tire yourself out that way.
It's all me now.
I
don't know where the doorknob is.
Wow, the moon.
I don't know where he is.
Oh shoot.
What are you talking about?
Happy Butter, I can't do this alone!
You left me!
What?
What do you mean there he is?
Wait, where did they go?
Oh, they're all coming down.
That's so funny.
Wait, I wonder if I can just hide here and CQC them each time.
Come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here.
Oh wait, he's gonna get...
Ok.
Nothing.
Rise and shine.
This is patrol.
All clear.
Understood.
Stay vigilant.
Why is my sneaking suit so bad even though it's night time?
I don't understand.
Can't be imagining things.
Please don't.
Oh, you're going the other way.
What's going on?
Oh shoot.
Can't be imagining things.
We're under attack.
Going to alert status.
No!
I'm just looking for a man.
Please!
I don't care about you guys.
Just looking for a guy.
What is that?
Wait, what do I hear?
I hear footsteps.
They're not coming from behind me are they?
That would be so scary.
All clear.
Oh my god, there's a guy right there.
But it is not Zadornov.
Oh, that's messed up.
Just aim, snake.
Zadornov!
What?
Oh shoot.
Wait, I can get him.
Oh shoot!
Why did you have to yell?
Speak!
Where did you see him?
Oh, you are so useless.
You are so useless.
Is anyone else around?
Even?
I think this was the guy down here, no?
Yeah, I heard him climb up the stairs.
Zadornov!
Where could he be?
No, no, no.
I tried to...I didn't want to...
Did you see him?
Gave the right answer.
Donkey.
OK!
You!
Metal Gear.
Fish.
This is the one from before, no?
It's...OK.
You!
Jackpot!
Mailing!
So cute!
Empty.
Nothing, yeah.
No worries, we know.
Oh, this one was so much easier.
All you have to do is actually not find him.
Oh, Capybara, I'm sorry that you disconnected.
I didn't need you.
Sorry.
Dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun!
When you meet...
Oh,
yes.
That's weird.
So that's Zadornov.
Yep, that's our guy.
OK.
We...
Then we'll do some side-offs.
Oh my gosh.
I thought you wanted to join us.
You liar.
We have Crane.
Crane, are you any good?
I like to call people on the radio when I'm on a mission.
It's a good way to get useful info and it reminds me that I'm not alone out there.
You're not bad.
I guess.
Could be worse.
Twelve months already?
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Where's your headband?
We gave it up, remember?
Well, I guess if you don't remember.
Snake takes it off at the end of the first ending.
Because he said the boss rejected him, so...
He rejects the one thing that he has of the boss.
OK, soon we'll get a better Fulton.
What should we do first?
Wait.
What's the mission where we get the palico?
Guys, which one is it?
I can't remember.
Which one?
Which one is it?
What we can do is a couple of these and stuff.
I don't remember what number it is.
Don't you need to listen to the Chico tapes first?
I did that!
Yep, yep, yep.
For the anybody...
For anyone who...
I guess...
I did a membership stream where I did a bunch of stuff off stream.
Or rather, in the membership stream.
So it was a bunch of grindy stuff.
That was...
So I just kind of wanted to be able to come in here and then...
Get a bunch of stuff.
Get stuff.
Died.
Yes.
Sorry.
29!
Thank you!
Extra Ops 29.
29, 29.
Ok, here we go.
Oh, it's just me.
How lonely.
Ok, start the mission.
Wait.
Oh, I need the C4.
I have the C4.
Let's go.
How would you ever figure that out naturally?
I... Actually, this one I don't know.
This one I don't know how would you figure it out.
Because obviously listening to Chico you'll figure it out.
Or rather, Chico will... I thought... I don't know.
The game doesn't tell you directly.
It's crazy, no?
See?
He's there!
Monster?
I miss my cat.
Poké Village theme.
Pokémon!
My sails pitched me out!
On that island there are undiscovered monsters that drop them.
It's up to be pretty handy.
We got it.
Do I still have to complete the mission?
A talking cat.
Nice!
Awesome.
Ok, so we have that now.
I kind of want to do this one.
Wait, this one.
Can we take a photo of the spirit roaming the small maintenance dock of the US Missile Base?
Spirits can be detected with the audio visualization equipment.
Let's get this mission started.
Complete the mission and proceed to the Fulton recovery point so we can get you back alive and well.
Good luck out there.
Thank you guys!
Basically we have to do missions now to have Zdornov escape again.
So fun!
I don't know.
So basically we can just do whatever we want until he escapes again.
So fun!
So what?
Do I need the camera?
Which I had, apparently.
And then, what was it?
The audio...
Not Soliton.
This one?
The surround indicator?
Audio visualization equipment.
Yeah, that one.
Oh!
It can only be me!
Lonely.
Ok.
Time for... Time for Fatal Frame.
Can you lure the freaky ghosts with magazine?
Maybe.
Freaky!
Wait.
Do I have to go around?
So spooky!
Is it down?
Maybe up here?
It's so scary!
Spooky!
Wait, let go.
Oh I can't.
Nevermind, just kidding.
I thought I would be able to hang.
A ghost!
I love how many random missions there are in this game.
Obviously, I'm a ghost.
Let's see.
How well did I do?
Piece of cake, he said.
Let's go.
Let's go, let's go.
S rank.
If I don't... If I get less than an S rank though...
In anything that is ghost related, I would be so sad.
Ghost photography.
Oh!
This one too!
Dead man's treasure.
Retrieve all the items from the Cloud Forest of Central Heredia.
Beware of ghosts.
Shall we try?
Heredia.
Heredia?
I don't know, sorry.
Trying to take a picture of a cute ghost.
Oh wait, she's right there.
Oh wait, I'm winking but you can't see.
Ok, who wants to join?
Don't die.
Oh, look back!
Don't forget your camera.
Oh, and your surroundings.
Mito, I plan on getting drunk tonight while playing DMC1.
Pray for me.
PS, it will wreck you.
Sounds like a Saturday.
What did you just put on?
What did you just wear?
Are you ready?
Let's go.
Gather all the... Retrieve all the items.
I do feel like I vaguely remember this mission.
Not all the 07s.
Let's go, baby.
I can't wait to do the final boss fight.
It's so good, you guys.
It's so good.
Oh, that's what you're wearing.
Where
is the ghost at?
I want to see one.
Curse you.
Oh wait.
This way.
Where is he?
I guess it doesn't work.
I got one item.
Where are we?
Sorry.
I'm scared!
I'm scared.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
What are you doing?
Oh my god, you son of a bitch!
I'm faster than the ghost.
I think.
Bye bye!
He's not coming after me now.
What?
I hear you.
I hear you behind me.
Whatever.
Who was that?
What are you doing?
What?
What the heck was that?
Wait, high five.
So scary.
Ok.
Anyway.
Oh, whoops.
Curse you.
I'm going to get this.
Can I save this guy?
Oh wait.
I want to save him.
Hold on, I'm going to try to.
Why does he moan like that?
How many more do we have?
Just one more.
Spooky.
It's so spooky.
Like a baby.
Over here.
Where is it?
It's got to be like on this side.
Nope, there it is.
I see it.
Where is it?
I'll help you!
Oh my goodness, what's going on here?
Oh, sorry.
Anyway.
Goodbye!
That was kind of sexy, no?
That was kind of sexy!
Right in front of me!
Oh there it is.
Oops, I messed up.
You missed.
Oops.
Thrilled, I'm sure.
Nice.
I don't think we are getting an S on that one.
That was so silly, right?
Alright.
Time for some of the more difficult missions.
Everybody.
Just kidding!
Great!
What?
I think...
That's a good point.
No kidding!
Oops, I didn't mean to press that one.
I meant to press the mission.
No kidding, huh?
It's so crazy too how much...
How much Kaz's tone has changed.
Since in this game to the other one.
96!
So close.
This game he's just like, yeah let's keep Zdornov.
And in the next game he's like, no people ever.
You guessed it, Zdornov has escaped from Mother Base again.
Find him and bring him back.
Okidoki.
You know, I might be crazy, but I'm pretty sure Zdornov has done it again.
Oops, he did it again.
He escaped.
We're at the Miner's Residence.
Vargara!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Maybe I will use the surround indicator.
Or night vision.
I don't know what would be easier to find him.
Something.
This should be fine.
Today is my birthday!
Pentomo poncho, happy birthday!
Gotta get a metal gear, happy birthday.
About to go to a convention, buy some more mint porridge.
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday poncho!
Happy, happy birthday!
Let's go.
Zdornov more like Britney Spears.
Oops.
Did it again with your heart.
What we probably will do is some of the side ops.
Before we do the final Zdornov mission.
Say we unlock it in a couple missions.
We'll probably just finish up the side ops.
And then go into the finale, finale.
Okey dokey.
Zdorn...
If I were a Zdornov...
Oh there it is.
Thank you!
Where is...who's dying down there?
Huh?
Okey,
I think we might have to continue onwards.
I don't...oh.
Anyway.
Can't be imagining things.
You might be.
You good boy Goro?
You wanna go to the next area?
Or do you think he's here?
Why was that there?
I thought he was gonna be under it for a second.
I thought he was gonna be in there for a second.
That was pretty crazy, no?
Wait, can I get the...
Assassin's Creed one here?
Hold on, hold on.
Wait for Goro.
I wanna try and get the Assassin's Creed.
Thank you.
I'm gonna try and get it.
Since I have an open slot...
I want it.
I want it, I want it, I want it.
What the...
No!
Mister?
You son of a gun!
Step on him, Snitch!
Tap his butt.
No, no, no.
Why am I saying it in like the severance?
Tap his butt.
Ok, that's enough of that.
Wow, that was so easy.
What?
There's so many items.
Stun box.
Big Boss!
There's like a song of...
What's it called?
Of the severance theme.
Like someone put lyrics to it and it's so stupid, but it gets stuck in my head too where it's just like...
Heli's hot.
Milchick's hot.
Everyone's hot.
Heli is hot.
She is hot.
Zadornov!
Can't believe he was in the love box.
Whatever.
Okie dokie.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wow, all because I wanted to do the Assassin's Creed.
All because I wanted to do Assassin's Creed I found him.
We have Rathalos right here.
Wait a second.
Is this...Are these the ones that we need to do?
So Chrysalis, Cocoon, Peace Walker.
If we do all of these then I can unlock the final date.
Imagine you guys might have run in circles.
I know, right?
You need the...Oh, the custom...I knew there was another one.
They unlock after the final boss.
Ok, nevermind then.
Well, I have to do something else.
Anyway, what should we do?
Maybe...
Let's do Rathalos.
No?
We gotta wait for him to go again.
We may also need to build Zeke.
So we wouldn't want to do these anyway.
Perhaps.
I don't know yet.
I don't know what you want to do yet.
Let's do...
You need to build Zeke fully.
Ok, then we'll do these battles.
And then we'll do Rathalos.
Again, we have to do a couple missions anyway probably because this is a door norm.
Let's do this one.
I'm scared.
Come on in people.
Go with the team.
Wait, where is all my...
Where is all my weapons?
Where is my buildout?
Combat.
Ok, fine.
I'll go with...
Yeah, you are so right.
Let's go with...
Good stuff.
Go with the team.
VENCERAMOS!
RPG.
Saber.
Then, chaff.
And...
Wait, is this the aerial mine?
Supply mark?
Wait.
Strike mark?
Maybe.
Wait, which one is...
Is this the flying one?
I can't remember.
Wait.
I don't even know which one I clicked.
Oh, it's the flying one.
Let me do...
Instead of RPG, let me do F.I.M.
Let's do the F.I.M.
instead.
We want the one that locks on.
That should be fine.
I guess it's ok.
Chat, is Snake invisible yet?
Or is that the other one?
Hole?
I'm confused.
I'm sorry.
Unequipped.
Yeah, this should be fine because we have the supply...
Let me also do... Wait, can I do the throwing supply mark or two?
Oh, I can only do one or the other.
We'll do this one then.
Rations, chips...
I got my camera.
I got my curry.
I got my stuff.
Ok, this should be fine then.
Lucky!
Brooks, Mobius, Chikara!
Look at us.
So worldwide.
Let's go!
Oh, I get it.
Invisible.
I get it.
I don't even know how that meme started.
I don't know either.
I just know that it's like blown up.
Hot, cold, man.
Oh,
you're in Amanda's outfit.
That's why I said venceremos.
I feel like we didn't... We needed a bunch of stuff for Zeke, but also not so much stuff.
So, I guess it's fine.
I was like, where the heck is...
No!
I totally, definitely...
Take cover?
Where is she?
Good
job team!
Where is she?
Change that.
Lock on!
Why did I switch to stop?
Holy cow!
Oh my god, you guys.
Holy... Holy damage!
She says, go see the Project Sekai movie!
I think I missed the last one, which is really unfortunate.
She...
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to steal your claymores!
It's an enemy closing in.
The dodge.
She's like...
Oh!
Are you okay, movie?
That was crazy.
Ouch!
I'm okay.
Kind of.
That was pretty rough though, not gonna lie.
Where is my supply marker?
There we go.
Please!
There we... Thank you.
Oh wait, is it gonna go on top of this?
I think I might have... Thank goodness, it didn't.
Oh, it's already reloaded.
I'm gonna do another supply marker.
Just have it.
This is my corner.
Okay, my bad.
My bad.
I have it ready though.
I have it ready.
My supply corner, yeah.
Oh, I missed.
Sorry everybody.
Sorry.
I got her tail.
I'm trying!
What do you mean?
What else would I use?
I tried.
Please, snake!
Reload!
They are sending out a cardboard box as we speak.
Dicado is taking a nap.
I love that.
Please ma
'am.
Please ma'am, come back!
I saw that.
That was pretty sad.
I saw that happen.
Such a cool looking boss.
I know!
She is so cool, yeah.
Ah, the kidnappers.
Where are you?
There you are.
No!
I missed!
You stinkin'!
I think that's gonna miss too.
It missed twice!
No!
She is too speedy.
I died.
Oops, I guess I died.
Sorry, I just...What are you apologizing for?
What happened?
What did you do?
Oops, I guess I died.
I'm going in!
Oh yeah, we gotta attack.
Thank you!
Oops, I guess I died.
I forgot you gotta hit it first.
I know, right?
How nice of her to line up so we can just sneak on in right there.
OK guys, take it.
Give me...Attack lots so I can get lots of parts please.
I don't remember what parts I need, but I'm just gonna take everything.
I'll just take as much as I can.
Take all the parts I can.
Give me parts.
OK guys, thank you.
Yep guys, I hear you.
I hear you buddy.
Grab the SSS.
Hmm...
I did not do it optimized.
Give me more time!
Please!
OK, Huey!
Thank you!
Oh, we just got a new one.
This one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, sneak!
Sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Oh, OK.
OK
Good haul.
Good loot.
We're getting stuff baby.
Good job team!
Good job everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Isn't there a way to extend the time?
There is if... I think they have to attack certain things on the guy outside.
To extend the time.
I didn't actually... I didn't optimize that, but that's OK.
We're fine.
It's fine, I suppose.
It's fine.
I meant hello!
Hello, hello!
Alright.
Valenciano.
You're welcome!
Thanks Huey!
Thank you for 12 months!
And then all of us just stare at it.
The stare is too funny.
Great job BisonWisp!
Thanks Rooks!
Yeah, let's go.
What?
Taking it slow.
S rank.
OK.
I didn't pull a single M.
Huh?
How?
I didn't pull that.
I didn't pull any M.
What?
Strange little fan zone.
Yippee!
I don't know how that happened, but it happened.
The game disconnected me after the mission.
Oh no!
Thanks for helping Jukedo.
The M is in their heart.
Walk unit.
OK, we still need that.
Are the legs...
What did the legs be?
What's first?
OK, so we're gonna try and get C parts.
We need pink.
We need...
We need pink?
Do I need both legs?
Or is it just one leg?
And we need yellow.
Yellow and pink are our priorities.
Just one.
OK.
Legs are the first thing, but it wouldn't let me put it down.
So we need the walk unit.
OK.
I guess you need something to attach the legs to.
Soon.
Let's go do another one.
That was great, guys.
Good job.
OK, so...
Pink and yellow.
Let's do cocoon.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Pink and yellow.
Alright, guys.
Let's do this, baby.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
To complete Zeke, you need parts.
You only get parts by attacking the AI pod, so the rest stays intact.
Attacking other parts gets you boards.
I see.
Snake!
Good boy, good boy!
Ride team!
Welcome team!
I'm gonna go with the team.
As I always do.
This is how we do it in SAO.
OK.
So we are trying to attack the AI pod as much as possible.
Thanks Mito for the fun battle.
Mobius, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Go with the team.
Yeah, try not to attack the armor points.
Armor parts as much as possible.
But I know it can't be helped sometimes, you know.
What's going on here?
OK.
Are we ready, team?
Y'all?
Any more time?
Yeah, yeah, so true.
This one is pretty slow.
So it's not too hard to hit only the pod.
That's so true.
True, true.
Snake!
Oh, there we go.
Snake?
Snake!
And Zdornov is still not even...
He's still...
Wait, so we're gonna have to fight all of these again?
As...
We're gonna have to fight all of these again, but in...
Uh...
The other mode?
You know, there's a human slingshot weapon.
Wait, really?
So silly.
Custom version.
Yeah, we have to do...
Yeah, I keep forgetting the name of them.
Custom version.
I guess that's OK.
Maybe I should have done these more off-stream.
That's OK, though.
But also, just getting Zdornov is so...
I mean, we have to do these anyways, because we got a complete Zeke, so...
I guess it makes sense.
AI pod!
Not Shucklehead.
Yeah, this thing is so ugly.
I'm sorry.
Huey, what the hell were you thinking?
This thing is a mess.
This thing is just... There's so many parts to it.
It's ugly.
It's just so ugly.
It's like Shuckle... The Shucklehead is pretty cute, but this is like...
It looks like a...
Like something...
It looks like...
Oh my god.
Hello?
Why am I... I'm not reloading.
Thank you.
Let's not have Lime Soda.
It looks like a toy truck.
Like,
you know, when you have a construction toy as a kid.
Are you OK, Berky-boy?
Wow, you dodged that crazy.
Tonka gear.
Yes, yes, yes.
What the hell happened to him?
Just making sure.
I did too soon.
Don't do that.
Metal slug?
It makes me think of that game's bosses.
Oh, I know what you mean.
I know what you mean.
I'm very
sorry.
I didn't see who raided, but thank you.
Not at me.
I want to get underneath it.
Wow, this thing is so tanky.
Lucky, thanks for the gifted.
Do you think it will happen?
Do you think it will happen if I'm under here?
It almost...
Scary, scary.
OK, not going over there.
Oh, I am out.
I'm just chilling here.
Is it really Miku?
It's actually a Vocaloid, yeah.
It is a real Vocaloid.
You're pretty good.
Margie's got his little corner over there.
You're dying, buddy.
Wait, who did we lose?
We lost somebody.
Oh Porkyboy, you're back!
Oh, it was the kind, kind health.
You're right.
What is...Am I hearing?
My goodness.
No!
Leave me alone!
That's to me.
No, it's not.
Just kidding.
Oh my goodness.
Is that at me?
You missed.
Oh no!
I think I'm the missile type.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, that's not good.
Be careful!
Wait, am I dying?
Wait, who is shooting me?
Run!
Porkyboy, are you OK?
Are you OK?
OK, you're fine.
I only have one ration left.
That's so bad.
Give me ration!
Oh come on.
Why did you have to go that way?
Are you guys OK over there?
Stay!
Gratty!
You guys alright?
Porkyboy!
Oh you just all had to match.
You just all had to match.
I just got there.
Going with no.
Gosh, this guy is tanky.
Like crazy.
It didn't release.
Why are you guys all dying?
I hear explosions.
Not
me please!
Don't die you guys.
Oh I haven't reloaded this whole time.
You son of a gun.
Do I have request strike?
Actually, I don't.
I thought I equipped it, but I think I forgot to since I didn't need it the last time.
Nice throw!
Wait.
I'm trying to get to her.
Thank you!
It didn't last very long at all.
I needed it for the fib, but that's OK.
Halfway through.
I know.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch.
I like how there's supply markers everywhere.
So funny.
I'm gonna need another one.
I'm gonna put another one down too.
I don't know why I chose right gear to lay down, but...
You stinky!
Did you do a smoke grenade so that she wouldn't see me?
That's so funny.
Thank you!
Let's go!
Not at me!
Where am I?
I'm actually trapped here.
I ran out of... oh shoot.
Guys, this is not good.
Oh my god, I'm trying to leave!
My chat froze, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Run Pinkie, run!
I'm running!
I don't think there's really any good use for me to go up there.
Use the ladder!
Okay, guys.
You're up there.
I see you guys.
If you get in, just get in!
Just get the pink and get the...
If you get anything...
Oh, I dropped it.
Why did I drop it?
I'm so stupid.
Run
out of supplies.
We'll have that pre-emptive.
Alright, good job team!
Close now.
Yeah!
So close.
Sorry I can't re-chat so much because you guys are so small.
Because it's broken on my YouTube side.
I'll refresh after the fight.
I'm so sorry.
This fight is so long.
RNG again!
Where are you?
Someone else get him.
Wait, where is he?
Are you up top?
What did Kota say?
You said he better be capping.
What does that mean?
I'm coming!
I'll try to get you!
Where the hell is the...
Weapon?
Where are you?
Oh
my god, I can't get to it.
I'm gonna punch this thing.
Wait, wait, wait!
Please let me on the ladder!
Thank you.
Right chair, are you alive?
Who's up here?
Nobody.
Oh, are you ok Snake?
I should be able to punch them from here, no?
Kinda messed up.
Who's down?
Where are you?
Snake!
Snake, where are you?
I see you.
Oh, Snake, I'm sorry.
I'm a little... Snake, I'm sorry.
I'm a little trapped.
I'm coming to get you!
Me first.
Wait, which one is mine?
I think mine is over here.
Almost there, so close.
So close!
It's too tanky!
Maybe we just redo some of the other, the easier missions instead, because my goodness.
This guy is so tanky.
Come on Snake, go up.
Everybody!
Maybe I should have done another.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Thank you for trying to help.
Me?
No, that's literally you.
Oh, I'm out of jabs.
Anyway.
Ouch, I keep taking damage because I'm a stupid man.
Come on guys, we're almost there!
We're almost there!
Oh, I'm done.
Am I?
Oh wait, it's me!
I'm the missile!
Watch out guys, watch out!
Snake, you okay?
It's almost there!
I'm taking damage.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I thought I was there.
I don't have anything to break it with.
Oh wait, I can grenade it.
Watch out!
I can't get in!
Pink and yellow, pink and yellow, pink and yellow, pink and yellow.
C and S.
C and S!
I know, I'm very curious how long that took too.
Gosh, that was long.
Wow, I'm gonna have to do it again.
It's gonna be even harder!
Oh, S!
C!
Why doesn't there seem like there's very many?
Oh no, it feels like there's so few.
It feels like there's so few.
That's it?
All of that for this?
No way.
Oh, this is so lame.
That's not a lot at all.
Oh, that sucks so bad.
No way.
We fought for so long, we got scammed!
Because you weren't destroying parts.
What?
No, someone said that I should only focus on the AI pod.
I need to shoot the other parts a lot.
But did I get one guide?
You want Metal Gear parts, not AI boards.
Oh, I get what you mean.
So we want them like... intact.
Wait, I thought the boards were what you use to build it.
I completely misunderstood the assignment then.
I see.
So because I attack, maybe the other parts will be intact?
I don't actually understand this part at all.
Oh wait, it doesn't say how long it took.
What?
No!
There we go!
You need a railgun from Chrysalis.
For faster fights, Battlesuit carries three weapons.
Gustav is the strongest launcher.
Thank you!
Parts for building Zeke.
Boards for outer ops.
I never understood how to build Zeke.
I never understood how to... I was just like, oh I guess I need pink parts.
Oh my gosh, now I get it.
I feel stupid.
Oh wow, ok.
So now we should be able to, no?
Does it matter which one?
I guess it doesn't matter.
They look the same.
Head.
We need the head.
I have PTSD now.
We just need the head!
And then what?
We need a railgun too, no?
I have a jetpack.
All the main parts must be set.
I have armor.
I have a railgun!
You guys, I have it!
I have it!
I have a
railgun!
I have a railgun!
So, we just need the head.
We need the head and we will be good.
What is this one?
Oh no, this one.
I got CPR'd by Minto, hell yeah.
Forgot I had one ration.
Oh, the ray dome.
But that's optional.
Okay.
Golly, that was a lot.
I feel like I need a break.
It's already been two hours of mission.
Sneaky snake, goes dancing.
So maybe...
To get the head...
Which one would I fight?
I am one leg part away.
You got this!
You can fight Pewpa.
Pewpa is not so bad.
So...
Pewpa, Pewpa, Pewpa.
Okay.
As long as the head isn't intact, we are not so damaged.
Okay, okay, okay.
Do we want to take a break from the...
From the AI weapons?
From the not metal gears?
Tough Scallions, welcome back!
There I go!
Time for some monster hunter.
This one is pretty tough too though.
This one is pretty, pretty...
But we are still waiting on Zidornov anyway.
Let's do Pewpa.
Let's make sure, let's get our...
Let's get our Zeke ready.
First off.
This one is not so bad guys, this one is not so bad.
Yeah, Rathalos is pretty.
Wow, you guys are so fast!
Sapphire Eagle.
Ill-ill-stoppable?
Mobius?
Let's go.
Okay, I love wearing my T-shirt though, but I guess it does make sense to have a third out...
Or third weapon.
Oh no!
No, I'm going with the T.
I'm too lazy.
I'm going with the T.
AI retaliate by spamming your feet with feet.
I don't know what you mean by that.
But I will bring a strike mark.
This guy is really fast though.
I'd have to like throw it and then like hope that it gets to him.
Alright, we ready?
Okay, only... Guys, once again, only attack the pod.
Okay?
Only attack the pod.
As much as you can, don't attack any other parts.
Only the pod.
We want all the other parts intact.
Go with the T.
You got it, boss.
Yeah, especially not the head.
Because if we can get two more... We need two more of the head.
So it's kind of rough.
T for four player battle gear for solo seems fair.
You know what?
That's true.
For future reference for Monster Hunter 7, do you want to go non-lethal or capture on the monsters?
Non-lethal has potential.
I didn't even realize you could go non-lethal.
What?
Really?
I didn't know that.
I think we'll be... Sorry, I can't stop yawning.
I think we'll be here forever though if we go non-lethal.
Amphibious AI.
Infinite banana.
Sleep grenade.
I see.
We'll see.
Let's get this first.
Only the pod!
He's so fast.
Stop being so fast.
The
head is going to get damaged.
Let's not have my lime soda.
I'm going to change.
Stop moving.
I tried to time it and I was a fool.
We'll just wait until this.
Nice save.
I think chaff will come in handy here.
Good thing I didn't shoot.
Not straight.
Just kidding.
This is fine.
At least, like I said, this one is so much faster.
We're already making pretty good progress.
It's just a little bit slower because we have to...
Wait, can I get down for this one?
That's what I was about to do.
No!
Shoot.
She's so cute.
Here
comes the Joker!
She moves around.
She's so nimble.
How did you get hit?
So funny.
I hate.
I miss the thing that didn't move.
I miss the one that didn't move.
I miss it.
This one moves too much.
Where is your target locking?
Not me!
We're almost there!
I died.
Oops, I guess I died.
Does anyone want to do it?
No?
I'll do it.
Anybody?
No?
OK.
That was so fast.
I'm glad.
I should have done more of this off stream I feel.
Or like in the member stream that I did.
Because it's so grindy at the end of this game.
That's just how it goes.
We're close.
We're almost there guys.
Don't attack the outside.
Just chill you guys.
You can just chill.
Hi Minda.
Hi Brandon.
Thank you.
Just chill out there.
Don't attack.
You're fine.
It's fun grinding with Minda.
The member stream was already pretty long.
I know!
We already did a bunch of...
A bunch of progress in that.
OK, let's go baby.
Oh, version of Peace Walker?
This is the Xbox version.
Yes, yes, yes.
Please, please, two head.
Please, please.
Two head.
Please, please, two head.
Please, please.
Please head and please make it two.
Scared.
Mother base.
So now our...
Metal gear...
Is primed and ready.
I think.
Alright, let's double check.
I'm scared.
Snake our head, let's go!
Let's go!
That was it, right?
We need one more head.
Two head.
I thought it was going to be no head.
Yeah, well we have to do it again anyway because the doorknob is...
Still around.
So yeah, we'll just do Pupa again.
You need a railgun too.
I have railgun.
I already checked earlier.
OK.
Let's do it again.
And then we're going to do it another time.
All this for a stinking date.
Welcome to Kato!
Welcome to Arby!
Welcome to Silver!
Let's go.
Do story Pupa.
Actually, you know what?
I thought about that.
It's fine though.
Or maybe we should switch.
I don't know.
It's all good.
Murphy, you good?
You didn't ready up.
And we're starting the mission.
Are you OK?
Yeah?
OK.
Dang it.
Yeah, it wasn't that long of a mission at all.
Because I had gear.
Your gear.
Your metal gear.
Strange love.
She's so beautiful.
Snake has such long eyelashes.
They're so pretty.
And then if the doorknob is not...
Gone by now.
After this fight we will do Rathalos.
Craving some lime soda.
Let's go Pupa!
One more time.
Just do the pod you guys.
Just aim for the pod.
Aim for the pod.
Oh wait.
My bad.
There we go.
Go!
OK!
Good job team!
Good job, team.
I'm gonna go up here.
What is this supposed to be?
It's...
Very much like a...
It's a stadium.
No, it's not a stadium.
Feels like one.
That was almost a really good dodge.
You'll just think I will always draw a snake with the most gorgeous lashes.
I know!
Where do you think she's at?
There she is!
Oh my gosh, making...
Her debut on the stage!
Oh, ouch!
Wait, help me!
Why me?
Hey, why me?
Ouch!
Stop it!
Please, please!
Supply!
There we go.
Thank you.
Sometimes my...
That was so close.
Oh my gosh.
Sometimes the... What's it called?
I think my controller is a little borked.
What?
Oh, the chap blocked the radio.
Oh.
Then you're right.
I didn't even think about it.
Wow!
Ouchie.
Chap, I didn't even think about it.
Oh god.
Today, you guys, I had to go outside.
Wait, that's me?
Oh, no it's...
Are you... Are you down?
I watched that happen.
I had to go outside.
I mean, like, outside, outside.
So, like, I had to take some allergy medicine.
I'm a little drowsy from it.
Are you still alive?
I'm not.
I'm dead, actually.
Oh, hello?
I'm actually... I'm actually a ghost.
I think pupa is so cute.
Is this the one you lay down for?
Okay, guys, come on.
Come on.
Oh, my rations.
How did I run out?
I was like, yeah, I was like, what's making me so drowsy today?
I forgot that I took the medicine.
And I didn't have...
Anything other than the regular, you know.
Non-non-drowsy.
I never get aimed for in the...
Oh, my gosh, my health is so bad.
Ouch.
Wait, who's down?
Oh.
Perfect.
Does anyone have a rescue box?
Yeah, we can hear the wee-woo.
Wee-woo.
That's what that is.
There it is.
The kid has got it.
Wait, can I get in?
Can I get in?
Oh.
Oh, it won't let me in.
No!
Oh, there it is.
Okay, just kidding.
I guess I didn't want to be in there for that long.
Yeah!
Wee-woo.
My health's not going up, though.
Okay.
Oh.
Wow, and we lost health.
Wow.
Okay, that's not good.
That was actually anti-productive.
Okay, let's actually beat this thing.
I'm tired of fighting them.
We're not very far in.
My curry!
How have I lost everything?
Oh, okay.
I was like...
This run is a little less unsmooth than the prior.
Yeah!
Is everyone attacking?
Is everyone doing their part?
I feel like.
Maybe.
Some people aren't attacking as strong as they should be.
Nobody forgot their weapons, huh?
Oh my gosh, again?
Oh, that was close.
I'm doing my part.
I don't think so.
Maybe I should have just done the story version.
I should have...
Guys!
Guys, I'm so asleep.
These fights are making me so sleepy.
At least, I think the other one was so long it made me so tired.
It was so boring.
No, I mean by the last one, not like the last fight.
That one guy.
Supply.
Wait, is that mine?
That's not mine.
Wait.
It
is?
But it's the yellow.
What is this one then?
What is that?
I tossed one early.
I forgot about it.
This is mine too.
Where are you, little lady?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
The exact same place too.
I know, I'm so consistent.
We're almost there, guys!
Keep going.
I didn't realize I was not reloaded.
That's pretty bad.
Just four more rounds of shots.
I sure hope so.
As long as we don't miss.
And by we, I mean me.
I mean...
Oh no, Chiquito.
I went the wrong way.
She was aiming for right here, no?
Rolled right into it.
I know.
So stinking cute.
Please,
thank you!
Almost there.
I'm excited for the final battle though.
I just gotta keep the eye on the prize, everybody.
We gotta remember why we're doing all of this.
We have to remember why we're going through this struggle.
Eye on the prize!
Peace.
Hell yeah, peace.
Peace day!
Oh boy.
I still shot it though.
Oh, I'm shot!
Wake up, snake!
Wake up!
Snake!
Snake, wake up!
Wake up!
I'm trying!
Wake me up!
Wake up!
Thanks, Chiquito.
You did have to pat my ass though.
Actually, apparently you did.
Actually, you know what?
I said that.
But apparently you did have to pat my ass.
Look how cute it is.
We're almost there!
We're almost there.
We're so close, you guys!
Please!
Just keep fighting!
Silver, you doing okay over... Ouch!
You doing okay over here?
Am I out of...
Well, luckily I have rations.
And
now, I supply my...
What are you joking about not being able to dive into a crowd during a live performance?
I can see you doing something like Pupa here.
I would love to, yeah.
Oh, let me get my stuff.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, okay.
Some courage.
Just a little bit more!
Why does this feel like ten times longer than the previous one?
Sorry, guys.
Maybe the other team was better.
She
doesn't stop boosting.
Maybe people aren't getting clear enough shots in the pod.
Maybe.
Here she comes!
Oh my goodness.
Right in front of me.
Oh, ouch.
Her ass is so fat.
Not a bad thing.
Positive.
Not complaining.
Oh my god, I shot too soon.
I shoot too soon all the time, too.
It happens.
I hear her.
I like hearing her when she runs away, though.
She's so happy.
She's just a little singing girl.
You think anyone's up in there?
Oh my god.
This is like her big ol' swimming pool.
We're almost there, you guys!
Please!
Finally!
Goodness gracious.
Alright, we just need a head, baby.
We just need the head.
We just need the head!
We destroyed it thoroughly.
There's like barely anything here.
She's all beat up.
She's stupid now.
Brain damage.
Brain damage!
I feel like Zadornov is going to be gone after this.
Chill.
Alright.
Brain damage.
Wanna bet?
Yeah, let's bet.
Five bucks.
I bet five bucks that Zadornov will be having it...
I bet you five bucks Zadornov will be... Oh gosh, maybe I got the brain damage.
Waiting for Mint to finally get a head.
Well, I had two before.
To be honest guys, I'm not looking forward to fighting this thing for the third time.
I'm not looking forward to it.
I'm scared.
And there we have it folks!
Murphy, nobody needs to know what happened outside.
Thanks Huey!
Why drop stuff giving me no rockets?
Oh.
That's weird.
I'm reading Headless Zeke to Headed Zeke.
Thank you.
Right, that's why we...
That's why we...
It's okay.
Uh.
Fine.
Thank you so much!
Thanks for joining!
Ah, okay yeah.
Uh oh.
Uh.
Cause we have an entire main story explaining why that doesn't work.
I know!
Oh.
Okay, do I owe you guys 5 bucks or...
Uh oh.
Oh no!
Boss loading nuke on Metal Gear?
Aw man.
Is there anything else in R&D we can get?
No?
Are you guys ready to color her?
Paint color!
Sage green.
No, I like the sage green.
I think it's better.
And...
It's kinda like...
Wait.
I feel like the turquoise is too dark, no?
Just got off a 13 hour shift!
Oh my gosh.
Tom Otsu!
I love how Kaz talks about a nuclear warhead like it's a puppy who followed him on ice.
Oh Kaz, he's just a guy.
Maybe white?
How did the 5 bucks you gave us just bounce back?
No!
The brown works too.
Wait, is there maybe a blue?
Who's determining these colors?
There we go.
Yay!
It's Sieg!
Metal Gear Sieg!
Oh wait, does she have the...
Oh, launch Sieg!
No, I did not do that.
No, I didn't.
Surely this will not backfire on us.
Look at the railgun.
Look at it there.
Sieg is so cute.
I always think of the little orb as a tiny, tiny head.
Any more optional parts?
Just this, but I don't have it.
With the ray dome.
I do not have a ray dome.
But that's okay, we completed Sieg.
Good job everybody, good job!
Good job, good job.
Shall we go do Rathalos?
Since...
The doorknob is...
Alright guys.
How do you get the ray dome?
I don't know actually.
You can fight main story chrysalis to get the ray dome.
I see, I see, I see.
This one is a little tough guys.
Oh, rocks!
Clanky!
Welcome everybody.
Alright, I'm gonna actually...
Wait.
For this, I will use the battle.
This one I feel... I'm scared.
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, maybe I should do this instead.
Are better rations.
And we'll go with the good curry.
The super curry.
Spicy curry.
We'll get some tortilla chips.
We'll get...
Shield?
Not going with the T.
I know I'm losing my...
I'm losing my...
That should be fine though.
Gustav?
Zlaniga?
Wait.
Let's do Fem.
Folks wanna know lethal or non-lethal.
Oh, let's do... We'll do lethal.
We'll do lethal.
It's okay.
I...
I don't know why I'm so tired.
I'm getting like...
I'm getting all...
Supply.
Strike.
Grenade.
Should be good.
Grinding does it too.
I think so too.
I'm like so... But I...
Even before stream, I took a nap.
I was so like...
So sleepy.
Oh, wait.
I just realized my curry.
What's the F curry?
Future curry.
That's right.
I wish I would sort it by like...
Best up top.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Should be good.
Are we ready, team?
Soda is... Oh, is this soda?
It says psyche, but I always...
Never use it.
I never think about it.
Alright.
Let's go!
I don't want to have more coffee today.
Because I already had coffee today.
Sorry, guys.
I'm so sleepy.
Rathalos!
Don't forget to cook rations here, folks.
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ.
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
You are forgiven.
Good luck hunting, boss.
You hear it?
Gonna have a bit of black tea.
That's actually what I'm drinking right now.
Some tea.
Well, it's not black tea, but...
It is like a green tea.
That's how you say keep you waiting.
Or kept you waiting.
In cat.
Monster hunter time, baby.
Meow, meow.
Let's go, team.
Are you sure it isn't meow, meow, meow?
I don't think so.
Oh my god.
Kept you waiting, huh?
Pig!
Going with the tea.
Oh, boss runner.
So cute.
It's so weird seeing this in Metal Gear.
Rathalos!
King of the skies!
Let's go!
Goal!
Ah.
Oh my god.
Watch out!
Oh my gosh.
I forgot he does fireballs.
No, leave me alone!
It's
okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Meow, meow.
Not the wind getting me.
Come on!
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Rooks!
Don't die on me!
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, game.
Game, gun buddy!
Oh god.
I think I missed.
Nice!
Shot him down.
I'm gonna cook my rations.
I'm the one getting cooked!
Okay.
Nice.
Good job team!
Damn!
Oh, ouchie ouchie.
Oh my goodness.
Everybody, we're okay, right?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Hey, chill out!
Little jerk.
Wait, where'd that guy go?
Where's the guy that took me out?
Where is he?
Do you think I'll be able to get him from here?
Let's test it.
Oh!
I was!
Pretty good.
I got you!
Oh!
Don't you die on me!
Are you just spamming that or is it one of those guys who says that every time you take a shot?
What?
Yummy!
I knew you had it in you.
I think it's glitched.
It's okay!
Oh my god, I think it really is glitched.
I think it's glitched.
I think it's glitched for real.
I knew you had it in you.
Where is he?
What am I gonna do?
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'll get out.
Oops.
Nice.
That looks delicious.
Sorry.
Oh, I have a lot of stuff.
Claymore?
Why did you give me this?
Cooking rashes instead of fire...
Ouch!
Leave me alone!
It's kind of hard right now though.
Because he is flying around.
Ew!
He is flying around.
Where did he go?
I got him.
And it missed.
That's so sad.
Nice hit!
That's me!
I tried to dodge.
Good job, team!
Or not.
What are you guys doing over there?
Come on!
Quit it!
Quit messing around!
Where did he go?
Please!
Wait, we can go fishing too!
Flash vomit?
I didn't bring that.
I didn't bring it.
I keep moving too fast.
Why are you guys getting hit?
Quit messing around!
Nice.
These fights are so hard to play solo.
Yeah, I believe it.
That's me.
Get up!
I'm trapped!
How did I live?
Or how did I make it?
I don't have anymore.
I'm completely out of supply.
This will be my area.
Like that.
Wait, what is this?
RPG?
Oh, okay.
Is he back in the air?
Okay.
My hidey hole.
Oh golly!
Whatever he does, it's an attack fight!
The game says no thank you!
The game says no thanks!
Oh my gosh, poor Palico.
He's king of the skies.
Yeah, but...
I don't know.
I just thought he might be tired.
Sorry.
Can I get up please?
I got me in the butt!
Look at...
He's so fast on ground too though.
We're so close you guys!
We're actually so close!
Good job team!
That's so stinky.
That's mean.
This stupid bird!
Oh my god, his tail!
There's nothing scarier than looking through your viewfinder and he's coming charging right at you.
I think that just blew me up because of the bird.
This guy.
Not a bird.
You know what I mean.
Are you gonna come at me?
Ouch.
He's getting a little aggressive I think.
I think he's a little upset.
I think he's a little mad.
It's a big ol' heckin' bird!
Stay down!
Where did I throw it?
It's like over here, no?
What do we do?
What are we thinking?
You think he misses his tail?
He looks like my cat now.
He's upset.
Upsetty spaghetti.
He took off his tail.
You think he's upset about it though?
Nice hit.
Sorry.
Clunky, I might have shot that at you.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
He's dead!
I thought he was coming at me.
Quick!
Grab some meat!
Grab a prize!
I'm a master hunter.
Carve him up!
Roast him!
Get away!
The tail...
The tail would have been so delicious.
Good job team.
We got some new stuff.
I wonder what it would taste.
Maybe like a crocodile.
Happy ending.
Aw.
I can find him.
There's a Rathalos armor set.
What?
This part is actually clever.
This part is pretty fun.
Okay.
Oh, is there a Rathalos?
Oh, I thought you said there is.
My reading comprehension.
And look, there's also Tigrex.
So...
Which one is it?
Is it this one?
The first one?
Let's first search Mother Base.
Special treat.
Let's search base first.
You know, he might still be around.
He might still be hanging out, you know?
So...
He might be...
You know, just about.
I'll do it by myself though.
Stealth.
We'll do sneaky.
Good idea, boss.
And you know, we can practice our shooting.
At the same time.
That's suspicious.
Snake, are you laughing?
What's so funny?
That was weird.
That was suspicious.
You guys hear something?
Did you guys hear something?
No, there's no way.
There's no way.
Oh,
I gotta reload.
There's no way.
Snake, what's so funny?
Snake...
Maybe perhaps we should...
Maybe...
Investigate...
Maybe perhaps...
He could be...
Hold on, maybe if I can...
Maybe he could be...
Hold on, if I can do this...
Oh, I wish we could jump.
Wait, hold on.
He could be...
Right under our nose.
He could be right under our nose...
The whole time.
The
whole time.
What
do you mean, minus two?
That was good.
Don't even lie to me.
Don't even lie.
Okay, I think I have to get him from down here.
Can we get him on this side?
Oh, nope.
Oh wait, oh.
This is why.
Aw man, I forgot it.
Plus two.
Thank you.
This part was difficult to decipher without guides or anything else shortly after.
I believe it.
I believe it 100%.
Rare actual cutscene.
Oh my god.
Are we gonna see Rocket Pierce?
I'm so excited!
What are you talking about?
V for victory!
Rocket Pierce!
You're so lame, Zdornov.
So lame, this guy.
Dies in one shot.
Guys, I found Zdornov.
I had to kill him.
Something's not right here.
I'm thinking he had a friend.
What's going on?
What?
Uh oh!
No!
V for victory!
Rocket Pierce!
Uh oh.
I've just finished building you.
I just finished!
Please!
Uh oh.
What?
Metal Gear Z.
Then how's it moving?
Modifications?
Oh my god, she's so cute.
Oh my god!
Pacifica Ocean!
I love you!
Uh oh.
No!
Pause!
Uh oh.
Oh yeah, I love me an expedition.
Exposition drop.
Zero?
I don't think you can divide by zero.
A world without borders.
A world without borders?
The Cold War order is about to collapse.
The age of electronic intelligence is about to begin.
The NSA, CSS, NRO, DIA, etc.
etc.
Bring on the robots.
The intelligence community that is long bickered amongst itself will be united in a world governed by electrons.
Cipher will gather all information, watching over the world and guiding the will of its people.
All while they remain blissfully unaware.
There will be no one to oppose them.
For the first time, the world will be ruled by a single will.
Until the new order is in place, you and your army will be the force that protects it.
You will be Cipher's deterrent, pulling the wool over the eyes of the old order with your charisma and military prowess.
Accept our offer and we will allow you to retain control of MSF and Zeke.
That's an offer?
Creep.
Cipher and his wife.
It's so dumb.
Cipher's going to control guns.
Control guns?
That's right.
Not deter.
Control.
It is the ultimate approach to the illusion of peace.
Control power.
You're gonna be disappointed.
Then we are done.
Thank you for playing.
The offer is received.
Lambda, thank you!
And now, the ultimatum.
Zeke is already in nuclear strike mode.
Uh oh!
I'm taking the weapon you built and using it to launch a nuclear strike on the east coast of the United States.
You're insane.
What are you after?
But wait.
Here is your consolation prize.
We are about to show the world just how dangerous a gang of outlaws, an army without borders, can be.
You and your men will become pariahs.
Prototype Rex needed a water room, I guess.
Rather than heroes, you will be seen as a well-armed extremist cult prone to indiscriminate outbursts of nuclear aggression.
You will give rise to a new world order, an age of deterrence defined by a fear of extremism.
So true.
Do you like the potential of being boss?
When all is said and done, peace is nothing but a fantasy.
A game is a game.
You either win or lose.
All you can do is fight.
Stop me if you can.
The peace sign is the V of victory.
Say...
Peace!
She's so cute.
She's too cute.
Pause!
Pacific Ocean, why did you do that?
Say peace!
She's gonna launch a nuke.
Snake, we've got to stop her.
Whatever it takes.
Awaiting your orders.
Ah!
Can't believe the love box No!
It meant everything!
It
meant...
Yes.
You guys ready for the last fight?
Before we do the last fight...
Should I listen to some of Paws' tapes?
Can't remember if I do it before or after.
Yeah.
I don't know why I didn't just press mission select.
I'm so used to pressing mother base because we always collect guys.
Zeke battle!
It's the last one!
Yeah, nice break before.
Before the fight, right?
People can join, but I'm gonna be listening to the briefing file, so Let's see.
Let's do, like, about herself, right?
Let's do these.
And then we should be good.
We know all this is a lie now.
It's just funny, but...
Mr. Superchat!
Thank you!
Thanks for fighting with us!
But his is in Japanese!
Cosplay time!
Now that I think about it, it's true!
What?
It is?
Wait, actually?
Uh-oh, I do it all the time.
It's true?
Yes?
Wait, what does it mean if I turn it around?
What about all, like, the gyaru babes who, like, do it by their eye?
It's like a middle finger?
No way.
What?
I learned that.
F you!
Maybe not anymore.
What?
That's crazy.
Backhanded pieces?
Like, I do it just to be cute.
In a way.
My aunts were kind to me and all.
But I know how difficult it must have been to suddenly have a child thrust into their lives.
When you live with someone, there are no secrets.
I could tell my being there was a burden on them.
Sounds like a rough childhood.
I would not say that.
I was lucky just to have people take me in.
There were funnels leaving out in the streets because their mothers died.
It is even worse in countries with frequent civil wars.
So, who am I to complain about my childhood?
You're a pretty tough kid, you know.
Not at all.
I am not strong at all.
Wee.
And last, a roll of Mother Base.
I have a favor to ask you, Snake.
Name it.
I want you to give me a job here.
I want to help out.
You sure?
You just went through hell of a time.
You should probably take it easy until you've settled.
She's so cute.
But there must be something I can do.
You would not want me near a gun.
But I am a decent cook.
Now, there's a skill we can use.
Put me on the mess hall team.
I think I can handle it.
Once I get used to it, I will even add in some Costa Rican recipes.
Sounds like a plan.
She...
You can't even select her.
I guess to not have you put her in combat would be so bad.
Ah...
She's our little mascot.
Okay.
We haven't heard...
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Pause this tape.
This is what I wanted to listen to.
Sorry, I was like...
I forgot about... I was like, wait a second.
I don't see the ones... And then all these messages from Eva.
Zulu?
You want to listen to her diaries before granting?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get the diaries after the final fight?
That's what I was asking before.
Oh.
I like how it's like, who could these two ladies be?
Why do they hate the East Coast?
Maybe because Washington, D.C.?
Is this Laurie Allen?
Yes!
Oh!
The sorrow.
Yeah.
I want someone to ask Chad JPT all of these questions.
It's too vicious.
Aww.
Who's there?
It's fine, they were mowing the lawn.
Yeah.
Oh, last mission!
Oh, it's so good!
I'm so excited.
Final battle.
I can't wait.
I'm already...
Actually, I should have gone to the bathroom first.
We're fine.
I'm so excited.
Best final boss fight.
It's too good.
I love this fight so much.
Okay, pause.
I love you so much.
And my cat.
I love my cat too.
Go on with the tea.
Half of Kaz's lines in this are...
Stop the nuke!
It's gonna launch a nuke!
Try not to beat her too fast!
I might just vibe.
Rations though.
Oh, shit.
The
little helicopter...
Or the little balloon.
Woo!
Yeah, we did this!
Is
that such a screw up?
Oh, Mobius!
Nice!
I died at the end of the song!
Oh!
Sorry!
Instrumental!
Oh my god.
I need to call more suppliers.
Mobius!
You got it.
Did you?
Pause!
Wait, transport?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, what was that?
Okay!
Pause!
Stop!
Mmm...
Pause!
I mean, she's not wrong though.
Dramatic pause.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought that?
He sounds so disingenuous all the time.
Huey!
Who would have thought?
Yeah, how would it happen again?
Oh god.
Who would have thought that a little girl would betray us?
Hey Snake!
Just in case you get betrayed again.
You might wanna...
You might wanna practice in case you get betrayed again.
Why does he look like that?
He looks like he's decaying.
Oh my god, she's so beautiful.
Good lord!
Pity.
Because I've just had my heart broken by someone else.
What?
I only like those who can stand on their own.
If you fancy me, then come walk with me.
Who knows what miracles might happen.
Love is blind after all.
Oh no, that's a bad TV show.
Actually, that show has proven anything.
It has proven that it is not.
I'll be waiting.
God, she's so beautiful.
Oh, strange love.
Don't do it girl!
No!
Don't walk, run!
Strange love, please!
God, if I had a time machine.
Lupus, happy birthday!
A kiss for a present?
That's probably the immediate offer.
Request, I mean.
Myth, you'll create a time paradox.
Oh gosh.
I just want her away from that man.
So un-serious.
I have a cramp.
Oh boy.
Gosh.
Everybody does that.
How does...
That's why he liked her so much.
She reminded him of Ocelot.
This mercenary business we built.
Someday it's gonna be a new driving force in the world economy.
Is that your goal all along?
The Cold War is not gonna last forever.
Does Kaz have teeth?
Kaz smiled for me.
Oh, I see them in there.
He looks like a toothless baby.
Poor economy.
Kaz, I hear you.
Please shut up.
It's all gum.
He's wearing that cypher outfit.
Kaz met Ocelot yet?
I don't think so.
It wore a chance.
Kaz, I'm Japanese, really.
He's just a little more charismatic.
And these people would rather our army without borders not exist at all?
Then who are we gonna fight?
The establishment.
Anybody who tries to restore the old balance wants to snuff us out of existence.
Which establishment?
It won't be a particular country or ideology that hunts us.
Who then?
We're gonna be fighting the biggest beast of all.
The Times.
Ten years ago, the Times rejected the boss and killed her.
And now, we are the ones being tested.
Will the Times erase us?
Or work with us?
It's gonna be a lonely battle.
No good or evil.
No winners or losers.
Christmas will have to wait.
The question we have to ask ourselves now is, can we survive long enough to see the 21st century?
I'm with you, boss.
We'll see how it turns out together.
What a simp.
You can't see it, but he had his little hand on it.
It looked like it was about to bow at him.
The time has come.
The hunt is on, Kaz.
And the whole world is on our tail.
Assemble the men.
Woohoo!
Thanks for this playthrough, Peace Walker Love!
Peace Walker Love!
Thanks Sam!
I love that fight so much.
I wanna do it again.
Assemble the men.
I'm sorry, I can't read all of this.
Noble Peace Prize.
Sandinista National Liberation Front takes hostages at a party in the House of the Minister.
Former prisoner of Costa Rica admits to collaborating with the CIA.
Apollo 18 docked in orbit.
Soviet Union invades Afghanistan.
Dr. Emery Kiwi becomes a father!
He names his son Hal!
Big Boss triggers the Outer Heaven Uprising!
She has a son named Haddad.
That's not his name!
And then yeah, the last one said that.
Miller is found assassinated and is home.
What a name.
Kiwi Hot Dog.
No, I mean...
Wait, Hal Hot Dog.
You're pretty good.
Congrats on beating Peace Walker.
Thank you Takedo!
Hot Dog Man.
Well done, big!
Peace Walker complete!
Thank you!
But what better place for us than this?
I honestly wish I were playing Ground Zeroes tomorrow.
Can I switch?
Is it Minecraft?
Can I play Ground Zeroes tomorrow?
I can do block game later in the week.
I can switch some stuff around.
Actually, I'm going to be 100% honest with you guys.
I was already going to switch games.
I was going to play Dredge.
I was going to play Dredge instead of Minecraft.
Well, it's Craftmine.
It's different, actually.
Donna Burke.
Ah, Donna Burke!
Yeah, Chris Zimmerman!
I like this place.
And...
I
think Ground Zeroes would be really good to follow up right after this game.
I feel.
This is such a good punch right after this game.
I think it might be good.
I'm doing it right now.
I have stuff to go after this.
Otherwise, I wouldn't.
And there's a couple of missions I want to do for Ground Zeroes.
So, it's not going to be just the one main mission.
The team was so pleased we're having another music video song as the last boss theme.
I know!
Jax can fight with our tiny souls!
This game is just...
It's everything I love.
Not enough ocelot, but...
Grants on beating Peacelogger, thank you!
Never enough ocelot, it's the truth.
We have a pause date?
No, no, we have to beat the game before we get it.
We have to beat the game before we get it.
We go over to Ground Zeroes and then Phantom Pain.
Ground Zeroes, Phantom Pain, and then...
That's it for all the mainline games.
Machi, thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
Thank you!
Then Delta.
I wonder if I'll be finished with 5 before Delta.
I didn't think about that.
Will I be done?
I have to finish Death Stranding 2 before that comes out.
Or Death Stranding also before Death Stranding 2 comes out.
Delta is in August!
Oh my gosh.
5 is extremely long.
But I think if I have mods, it won't be so long.
I think if I have mods, it won't be so long.
What did the mods do?
You can get mods that have every soldier you extract is S rank.
So that would help with a lot of R and D.
You can have one that makes it so that when you develop stuff, there's no time.
So it would develop things immediately.
Yeah, otherwise V is very, very grindy.
Even more so than this game.
Congrats on beating V Swagger.
Thank you, J!
MGS2 for April 30th.
I already did MGS2.
And the skateboarding.
It lasted.
Not even a hello?
We fight because we are needed.
We will be the deterrent for those with no other recourse.
We are soldiers without borders.
Our purpose defined by the era we live in.
We will sometimes have to sell ourselves and services.
If the times demand it, we'll be revolutionaries, criminals, terrorists.
And yes, we may all be headed straight to hell.
But what better place for us than this?
It is our only home.
Our heaven and our hell.
This is Outer Heaven.
Red
Nice Nice
Nice, nice, nice.
Someone who played MGSV 10 plus times.
It goes by faster than you think.
So sick of that damn hospital.
Congrats on beating the game boss.
Thank you!
We still have a little bit to do.
Still have a little bit to do.
But didn't I say I unlock stuff?
Liar.
Yeah, the intro mission for V is... yeah, something.
Hold on.
I offered a host.
I can solo all four customs?
No way.
Micmac, are you insane?
Customs are much stronger.
Wait, hold on.
I don't even have them unlocked.
Oh wait.
No, this is a custom.
Wait.
Ah, I see, I see.
OK.
Wait, I...
Once I do Pupa custom, I imagine the others will be unlocked, right?
I hope so.
Last time we'll hear David Hayter.
I know!
It's so sad!
It's so true.
We really want to get that cause date.
Red skull is spooky.
No way.
Micmac, you can do it.
I can solo all four customs in 8 minutes.
The last type 2 mission took almost 25.
Customs are much stronger.
OK.
Alright, Micmac.
I'm taking you up on that offer.
That's insane.
How the hell?
OK.
Save me, Micmac.
I saw that art.
It's so funny.
It's so... Actually, OK.
If I...
Thank you, Micmac.
It's movies!
Oh wait.
I... Wait.
Cancel, cancel, cancel.
Unable.
Alright, Micmac.
I'm just going to keep searching.
Nobody else join.
The customs are mostly about endurance.
Anyone else want to join?
I'm already in battle.
I have to pee so bad though.
Putting your money where your mouth is, Micmac.
8 minutes!
Oh dang.
You're so lucky that my...
That my screen is being used.
That my second monitor is being...
Wait.
I have a third one.
You're so lucky my third monitor doesn't have...
Have...
I would pull up the stream timer.
I would pull it up.
But I can't access it because I don't have my Windows bar.
I have to pee so bad.
If I just stand there, will I be fine?
Good luck everybody.
I'll be right back.
Don't save me if I fall.
Party break while you get a show.
Alright.
If I come back and Micmac is done, that means...
I definitely think you should try streaming this game more for 100%!
Holy...
100%
You're timing it?
Okay.
I'm gonna go get more water.
Neutralize the Pupa AI with it.
Dinner and a show.
Ew, Reggie, get off of me.
What the fuck?
Yeah, go away.
Do something, bot.
I
thought I'd be dead.
Not gonna lie, I thought I'd be dead for real.
I only got hit once?
No way.
That's insane.
No way!
Micmac?
What
do you mean you can solo with it?
I got you, Mic.
Were we bamboozled?
Hold on, I'm gonna keep eating my sushi.
I've never seen him red.
It's kinda cute.
I like the alt color.
I think there's HP scaling.
I wonder how.
Oh, you're alive.
You should watch back the footage of your break sometime.
It's funny.
Crush me like an insect.
She's so cute.
God dang it.
Micmac, have you... Have you never done this fight?
Like, in multiplayer?
You're doing so well though.
We're already like halfway.
A little less.
Well, more than halfway, but...
Oh god.
Co-op scales.
No way.
No wonder things were crazy before.
It's okay, Micmac.
I believe in you.
Oh gosh.
Don't kill me.
Please don't kill me.
Oh my god.
I'm out of everything.
Did I not bring any food?
I might be stupid.
We're at six minutes.
Oh, Micmac.
I saw that.
This is still I feel better though than...
Even...
When it was the last team that did P1.
You guys, eye on the prize.
Eye on the prize.
Remember who we're... A girl worth fighting for.
I want her in a Speedo.
And... That's about it.
I want her naked on the beach.
And going inside my box.
I could care what she wears.
I want a Speedo.
I really hope she has a Speedo.
Oh golly.
A lot of people are saying what?
We're in for it.
Eye on the prize.
I'm safe.
We're almost there.
Time for
you to die.
Might be me.
Free pizza!
Micmac, I hope you don't feel bad.
I'm really, I'm really, I'm really grateful for you to help so much.
Yeah, you can do this!
I don't feel, I hope you don't feel like... Oh my goodness.
Are you ok?
I hope you don't feel like... You think I'm upset or anything.
Wow.
I really missed that.
You should grab those, you should grab those, those rations right there though, buddy.
These ones right there?
You should eat that.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Sorry.
I can't breathe.
Sorry,
Oopsie.
You know what though?
Ok.
As soon as she's on top of there.
Yeah!
That was good!
No!
That was good, no?
That was awesome!
I did that, I did that.
Micmac for TwinkleDogsChart 2.
I might be down.
I'm not down.
I'm still good.
Almost there!
I
want the finishing hit.
Let me finish her.
Get off of me!
Shamed!
No!
Thank you
for the... You really didn't have to say that.
I feel so bad.
You killed it!
You crushed it!
Like a bug.
Like a pupa.
And now we have to do it three more times?
At least we don't have to do that fight again.
Thank goodness.
No more pupa!
The battle was so fast.
Also red costumes.
Again!
Cocoon will be the worst.
Do we also have to do Peace Walker?
Yes!
Guys, eye on the prize.
There is a man in a speedo waiting for us.
He...
He is waiting for us.
Eye on the prize.
How do I unlock the human... the human torch?
Oh!
I missed the tape.
What are you talking about?
What did I miss?
Hold the pause... Oh!
Oh, sorry.
I completely forgot about it.
Hot blondes and triple agents within your mother base.
My bad.
Sorry guys.
It's OK.
I don't think we have to do it.
Yeah!
Alright, Micmac.
Trusting on you part 2.
When I join 2, I've got the max level M47 rank 5.
I can't tell if you're being serious or not, Lambda.
I can't tell if you're being serious.
If you could join, why didn't you...
Why didn't you ever join?
This feels suspicious.
I wanna join Minky Room, but I'm from Southeast Asia.
And the same people keep joining...
Yeah, do you have the slingshot?
I wanna see the slingshot.
I wanna see internet.
Let Lambda in.
Let Lambda in!
Just let someone named Sukuna join.
Sukuna join!
Let nobody else join!
Aw, Brooks, thank you.
I will remove the bandana and quit my rations.
OK.
Oh no, no, wait!
Lambda, do you wanna join?
You can join, like right now.
This is... Everybody is being so nice to you.
Let's go!
What am I playing on?
I'm playing on Xbox.
Alright.
Also, Petman, I'm so sorry.
I saw your dono just now.
MGSV time, yay!
OK, are we going?
Oh wait, let me equip more food.
I'm stupid.
I have no more of these rations.
Wait, can I equip this ration too?
Yeah, OK, good, good, good.
OK, now ration and the curry.
OK, OK, OK.
OK, I'm good.
That was the cooked ration.
Yeah, yeah, I ran out.
Yeah, thank you guys so much for being so courteous.
Oh wait, OK, I have the FIM.
We don't really need the strike marker, but that's OK.
OK, I'm ready!
Let's go baby.
Yes.
Good luck.
Eye on the prize, eye on the prize, eye on the prize, eye on the prize.
I'm just thinking about it.
Thinking about it.
I'm thinking about it, I'm thinking about it, I'm thinking about it.
Getting an airstrike on a flying boss would be a real flex.
I agree.
There is a chance.
There are some points where he gets pretty low, but...
Sukuna said 5 minutes.
Are we timing?
Yeah.
Time!
No one is exempt!
I'm in the back and I'm soaking!
This one is tricky just because he is so all over the place.
We got this, easy.
No worries.
5 minutes starting!
No!
Did that shoot?
I don't know if that hit.
Chrysalis is so cool looking though.
Where are they landing?
Over there.
I guess it doesn't really matter where we...
You got this.
I believe.
We got this!
Wow, we already done like a pretty sizable amount.
Really?
Wow, did you see that dodge?
I want to do the human slingshot.
Oh my god.
Bit back!
I can't stop it.
I can't stop it from happening.
Just let it happen.
That's because I'm out of stuff.
Sorry.
It's my fault.
Stupid kidnappers are so annoying.
Damn, that was not good.
I keep missing.
Oh shoot.
You need at least one component to develop a part of the slingshot.
Obtainable hunting monsters.
I see.
There's got to be someone who has it.
No!
How did you hit it?
I'm just that good, baby.
I'm just that good.
That's not for me.
That was close.
She's normal.
Damn it.
Where is she?
Good job, Trip!
Four minutes?
Oops, I guess I died.
Yo!
Lambda was so legit.
Go!
Go in!
Tape!
I will this time.
Before I was distracted.
Good job, Micmac.
Good job, Lambda.
You guys were great!
And of course Silver, you too.
We were just there.
We were just, you know...
Thanks!
You and I are probably in the same category.
Just being there.
We were just pinching it while they were punching it.
We were pinching it like...
When does it come up?
Oops.
I didn't see it.
When I'm moving I didn't see it though.
I couldn't get it this time.
That's OK.
I see.
Next time.
I say it again.
We'll get them next time again.
And again.
Alright.
That's two down.
Oh my God.
Crazy.
Alrighty.
How many left?
I believe there are just two more left.
Cocoon.
Finally!
You can count on me again if you want, Buzz!
Lambda, you killed it!
Literally!
Literally.
So yeah, Cocoon.
Peace Walker.
That's it.
Do I have to do the Peace Walker Type 2 to unlock the Cocoon?
I might have to, huh?
Oh shoot.
Wait, do we have to do Peace Walker Type 2?
Let's see if it shows up after Cocoon Custom.
Thank you.
Hey Leo!
What are you doing taking my spot, eh?
OK.
How much curry and stuff do I have?
I guess enough.
OK.
Pretty sure you have to beat Type 2 to unlock Custom.
We'll see!
We have to do this fight anyway, so...
Who did we lose?
Oh, there you go.
Let's go!
Let's try not to have this one be another half hour.
Please God!
Please have this one go by quickly, please!
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please.
McMac, we're all counting on you.
You know that.
No pressure or anything.
No pressure.
What I ate.
I was so sleepy before.
I won't this time.
You won't what?
Eating only made you more sleepy.
Oh no!
I got stuff I gotta do after this.
But it's already been four hours.
I don't know if I'll be able to finish my stuff.
No!
OK.
But it's for the mission.
This is our last time playing.
Peace Walker, we gotta get the date.
It's important to me.
Because I've never been able to do it on my own.
I've never been able to get it.
I'm gonna work on the guns.
Just kidding.
Note to self.
Give a little bit more room.
Stop it!
OK, I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
Yeah, you're welcome McMac.
It was completely targeted on me.
What if I do a strike marker here?
It's
already like so...
Yeah!
Don't
worry about me.
I'm just a little dead under...
Everybody is so used to me being dead.
They are like what?
What?
Don't come in here.
Do not come in here.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Get McMac first!
Yeah, I kind of wish he got me first.
Wait, now I feel a little upset that I wasn't prioritized.
A little self... OK, you can't get the wheels.
They don't do anything.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
I can't stop getting hit.
How did I make it?
Gotta hit the vents.
Oh wait, that didn't do anything.
Or did it?
Let's see.
No,
I'm not doing another strike.
I'm out.
Well, the vents are done, maybe.
Give me my curry, please!
Use the ladder.
I'm trying to stop it, Leo!
Stinking chainsaw thing.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Random Rathalos boy.
I know, it's so funny.
Let's go.
Use the ladder.
He's so funny.
He sounds so done.
He's like, use the ladder.
I'll go up now.
Micmac, you're killing it!
Leo, you're killing it!
Illunstoppable, you're killing it!
Everyone's doing so good.
Wait!
Stop!
Wait, wait, wait!
I'm coming!
6 minutes 28 seconds.
That was sub 8.
Okay.
One, maybe... One or two, we'll see.
One or two.
We'll see.
One or two more fights.
Okay.
I pressed it!
I got it!
I did it!
There's so much in this game.
God, there's so much in this game.
Mosquito data is as good as ours!
I know.
Yeah, the tape was humongous.
I wish I had more sushi.
I ate most of it before streaming.
I wish I had more.
Not
enough sushi.
I want more sushi.
Eat track tape.
Am I going to try portable ops yet?
What do you mean yet?
I've played portable ops before.
But, I don't know.
As portable ops, I don't want to do the fight.
I don't want to do Gray Fox.
I hate that fight.
I hate fighting Gray Fox.
Let's go team!
You obtained Paws' Diary Part 1.
Let's listen to it real quick before we...
Before we continue.
Let's continue.
It's hard to go back to portable ops after Peak Walker.
I know!
It's true though.
To everybody who thinks that you need to do type 2 battle before getting custom...
You did not!
Nice!
One more battle!
Ok, wait.
Hold on.
I'm not going to do it, but I want to listen to the tape.
He's so efficient.
I love you
I love you I love you I love them
What is wrong with them?
That's ironic, huh?
Alright.
One more battle, huh?
McMurk!
Thank you!
Who's in there?
Clanky!
And Sapphire.
Okay.
Can I join this Peace Walker battle boss?
Oh, this one is pretty beefy.
You need a lot of firepower.
I think both Clanky and Sapphire have played before.
If anybody would like to give up their spot, anyone would be so kind.
Thank you!
Thanks, Clanky!
Sorry, Mint.
This one takes me 20 minutes solo.
It sucks.
Okay.
That's why I didn't want to do the Type 2 version.
Because I was like, already I feel that it would be...
Thank you!
Okay.
This is a toughie, guys.
This is a toughie.
Always happy to help a fellow Wisp.
Thank you!
I'm scared.
We got this.
Alright.
Combat!
I believe in us.
We got it so fast when we first did it.
So, this will be like a true final battle.
Eye on the prize!
A girl worth fighting for.
I couldn't win this until I rank 5, Gustav.
Gosh.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
I think it's just a little bit slow.
I don't even know if I'll be able to do much.
But we got this.
You're bugged!
Wait.
No way.
Lambda can host.
Wait.
If you're...
Someone go play with combat drone.
Someone go play!
There's two people.
Oh there's three people!
Don't forget to let Lambda in, everybody.
Please be so kind.
Thank you, thank you.
Just so I would...
Just so that we can actually...
Get through it.
Is this the last?
It is the last!
Mobius, thank you.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
I completely ranked and grinded out PSP3 S3 file.
This one takes a while.
Okay.
Yeah, I would...
For any of the other fights, you know, anybody could join.
But for these ones, we need people who are like...
Who have ranked up their stuff a lot, so...
I apologize.
We're in.
No
problem.
Thank you.
Yeah, we got to get S rank wisps.
You can't argue with five red skulls.
I know.
I shouldn't even be in here.
I don't belong here.
Lambda, you might need a host.
Combat...Someone play with combat drones!
Please, we're on the final battle.
Please!
I wonder if I can even get in.
I'm in!
Okay.
We're good to go then?
Do we need a Mic Mac?
Sapphire, how good is your stuff?
Are you like full Mac?
Full ranked up?
If they have it unlocked, they probably have good stuff though.
What?
Full Mac?
Did I say that?
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
Full Mac...
I'm at full maxed.
I messed up.
It's all good, Vic Boss.
Okay, I guess we'll go then.
I don't see them in the chat.
Mac and cheese.
Can I get a full Mac?
The big Mac becoming...it makes you full, you know?
Let's go!
I'm full Mac on PSP, PS3.
What do you mean?
People who are stuck in the iOS system are full Mac.
Let's go, baby.
I'm scared.
This one is hard.
This one is so crazy.
I'm scared.
Strange love.
She's so hot.
Save me, beautiful woman.
Save me.
Save me, hot lady.
What's she got in her pocket there?
A little red something.
Cecile.
I wish Cecile was never heard from again.
Cecile came and she went.
Goodbye, Cecile.
I
was about to say I could swap, but I didn't type in time.
It's ok.
Let's do our best.
We got this.
Thank you so much for the loot.
Thank you.
I know the beauty mark.
Is she...Is Peace Walker just tanky?
Or...
Everything.
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
Extremely.
Extremely tanky.
Very tanky.
Red Peace Walker is too cute.
So stinking cute.
Where are you going?
Maybe I can get her from in here.
She's so choppy.
Initializing nothing.
Try this on for size.
I wasn't even trying to hide.
I thought I wasn't going to get it.
I'll try this on for size.
We are already halfway there.
This is crazy.
What are those?
It just dug into the ground.
Thank you.
Where are you?
You guys are making great time.
For real.
Oh shoot.
Wait.
What?
The counter disappeared
so I think we are ok.
Bring it on!
No!
Don't do that!
Ok.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god!
Not the flame BB!
No!
The flame BB is too...
Oh shoot.
Please.
Hang it up.
I'm
going to die.
I'm actually doing so...
I'm totally fine actually.
I want to just get in on the action before we, you know, destroy her.
Mobius!
Don't die!
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
I almost died there.
Get up snake please!
Snake!
This is so lame.
Am I going to be...
I'm going to be... Wait!
I want to shoot!
I'm ok.
Thank you.
I want to at least get in a final hit!
One of the final hits!
A final hit!
How do you get in?
Oh here we go.
I'm in!
Wow!
Team!
Thank you everybody for helping this group effort!
This is great!
So fast!
Well done!
Yeah!
You guys killed it!
Good job!
Told you nothing to worry about.
Truly.
I feel like...
I got hurt more in other...
Jackpot for real.
Got it!
That's so many boards!
I've never seen so many.
I guess... I feel with Peace Walker it is difficult to get the AI pod.
Like it's pretty... This is kind of like tucked in under her head so...
So the pod ends up being kind of not...
So damaged compared to the other places.
Just shy of 6 minutes.
Wow!
Yeah it's hidden under the giant radar dome.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
So it's a little more tricky to get in there.
Tucked in and you have to attack the body when she launches a nuke.
Yeah baby!
Goodbye Peace Walker again.
Goodbye
Peace Walker again.
Peace.
Peace out.
Do I sound like the vampire?
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
They'll never hear me coming!
Obtain Paz's diary part 2.
Let's rank.
Let's go.
Crazy.
Count Minto.
I'm scared.
What if it's not there?
I'm scared!
Snake...
Would you be up for going to the coast to watch the sunset?
Just the two of us?
His favorite color.
Let's rock.
Now does he like the same things Paz liked?
Is the question.
I don't have the sunset yet, no?
Don't I have to...
I can only get it from this, no?
I don't have the sunset.
Trunks' Paz.
No, I got the...
Wait, no.
I never...
Sorry.
Sorry Kaz.
What's he got?
Wake up.
Ah!
Hey, come on now.
We're friends, aren't we?
Naturally.
Why was it a fist?
Because of you Miller.
That was not a clap.
Why was there a fist clap?
You're pretty good.
Cut it out.
You're making me blush.
I'm with you.
You can do this.
Snake, you're gonna make me cry.
Good to have you.
Hey, come on now.
We're friends, aren't we?
Stop!
Oh
no!
Don't clap.
Wait, I don't think he'll like that one.
No!
Don't play.
Don't die on me.
You too.
Impressive.
Cut it out.
You're making me blush.
I like you too.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to touch that.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Wait, I just threw my hands everywhere.
Sorry,
we're blowing it.
I got nothing to hide.
Make sure you get a good shot of my muscles.
Can I please?
I think I can't do that.
Stop
it.
Stop it.
Get a pic of the pack.
Oh, sorry.
He looks so stupid.
Oh,
got room for two.
This playthrough is one of my favorite MGS experiences.
I didn't mean to pull a Johnny Akiba at the end, but I always enjoy seeing your love for the series.
I hope you can convince your friends to beat the series because watching you has been a great ride.
Thank you, McMahon!
Thank you for your help with the vital boxes.
And all the other stuff too.
If it isn't Sussy Mint.
How do you get that other outfit?
How do you get the bathing suit?
I S-ranked it.
So good.
Lost a lot of bros and shambles.
Oh, it's on the docks.
I have to get it with Paz too.
Let me go get it.
Holy cannoli.
We'll just go as we go.
Vassalat will always be my OTP.
But this is like a fan service beyond...
Only people...
I forgot that she's a...
Sorry!
Sorry Paz!
Oh sorry!
Sorry!
Creep!
Oh, whoops.
I messed up.
I won't run at you.
I'm going to run over here.
I see it, I see it.
I forgot to grab it before.
Citrix!
You're really lucky you're a woman.
I'm so glad I'm a woman!
Like the crack!
The crack of dawn, baby!
Golly!
Sorry!
No, don't run from me!
Paz!
Paz, please!
Paz, don't run from me!
Stop!
Stop my beautiful angel!
Ok, wait.
Did that count?
I still got it, right?
I have goosebumps.
Oh wait.
Oh no, it didn't count!
I have to go back in again and again!
Ok, Paz, I won't scare you this time.
I'm so sorry.
I won't scare you.
I won't scare you this time.
I need to beat it correctly.
Rinse FBI agent.
She's guilty!
Ok.
It's not my fault if I run.
She gets scared.
Yeah, act natural everybody.
Act natural.
What are you doing like that?
Sorry.
Did you come here to swim?
It's too dangerous.
Ok, I'll stand over there.
And you stand there.
You're pretty good.
Stay away from me!
I don't think she likes me anymore.
I'm with you.
Bonnie?
Why not Bonnie?
I like my Bonnie.
She hates me!
I think I have to change.
What do you mean?
Are you here to swim?
She hates me!
How do I get out of the mission?
How do I get out?
She's so cute.
You're going to take a picture of me?
Oh my god, she's too cute.
She's too sticky cute.
Gosh, she's so cute.
Wait, when she turns and you see the little bit of cheek...
Right there!
Do you see it?
Do you see?
And there!
Hold on, I'll get closer.
The other angle was better.
There, you see it?
Pies, can you lift your arm?
Fix your hair?
You're going to take a picture of me?
There!
Don't move.
Why is she spinning with us?
Oh sorry.
Sorry Pies!
I think that's a lie.
Does she have anything on her?
Wait, come here.
The way she stomps away is too cute!
This is how I sound when I'm yelling at my cat.
Pies,
wait!
Pies!
Alright, properly.
We're going to get the bathing suit and then we're going to go back to Kazahira Miller!
She wants a tux.
Why do I have all this stuff on me?
This is our Oshi everyone.
Hate to see her leave.
Love to watch her go away.
Yeah baby!
I'm going to wear Miller's outfit to Miller.
Nemi!
Oh gosh.
Hello Nemi!
Nemi, please look away.
Nemi, please.
Nemi, Nemi!
Please look away.
This is just a cute girl in her lingerie.
I'm not doing anything suspicious.
Definitely not getting that little cheat.
Bam!
Oh god!
Right there!
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you!
I'm getting nice sunset pictures.
Of Kazahira Miller.
It just so happens.
It's a nice view in more ways than one.
My bad.
Now I have to woo her everybody.
Hello?
What a time for a Nipi raid.
How do you think of Nipi?
Matthew, thank you for the 5k.
Thank you!
We are not going to try and S it.
I like it.
Ok, now watch what happens.
Oh sorry!
Room for one more?
It's just like The Sims!
Yes!
Now watch this too!
Watch this one too!
Watch the next one!
Metal Gear is really exciting, right guys?
Amazing!
That right there is why you are the best boss.
How old is she?
She is in her twenties.
Don't worry.
Oh, I shouldn't have skipped it.
You know, it's fine.
Wait,
wait, wait, wait.
Ok, we got enough.
Fine beach side photography skills boss.
Thank you!
Kazuhira!
And then, hold on.
We are going to go through this one real fast.
Oh my god, we are matching!
Wait, somebody has to change.
Wait a second!
Wait, wasn't there a speedo?
Or does Snake not have the speedo?
Twinsies.
I wish I could get like a...
Oh my god, look how cute they are.
I think you may have unlocked it if you S rank him.
I did S rank him though.
I need an adult.
Oh,
wake up!
Wake up!
I don't think you want this nightmare.
You need to beat it in the swim trunks.
Ok, hold on.
Let's leave.
Yeah that guy, Kazuhira Miller, he is from Japan.
I love
the beach.
Wait, where is my camera?
I love the beach.
Jump!
There it
is!
This is true peace.
Why would anyone wear this on the battlefield?
It's a mystery.
I know it.
God, look at... wait, wait.
You can see... look at Snake's...
Why
is it so... here, I'll do a level.
Oh,
sorry.
Oh no, he's serious.
I like how the song is just so sad, but...
Oh, sorry.
I accidentally ran into you.
Listen to me.
Ok, the music needs to change.
Where is this from?
We'll do Calling to the Night.
Oh, sorry, I go too fast.
Oh,
sorry.
I guess it's a fun game.
This is interpretive dance.
Now he runs into the sunset.
No, he didn't like it!
No!
Guys, no!
What do you mean?
He'll probably still want to go in with us though.
Welcome to Metal Gear Solid!
I made the official Calling to the Night music video.
Anyways...
Yeah, that was...
That was Metal Gear!
Wait,
2 perfectly.
Wait, what other raid did we get?
We got 2 raids?
I enjoyed my stay.
Oh, Doki!
Oh no.
Wait, Doki at the same time?
I didn't see it.
Boss and Kai's steam room audio on YouTube?
Oh yeah, I've listened to it.
Oh, Dragoon self-raid.
I'm going to relate that song to that moment every time I hear it.
Well guys...
To everybody who raided, thank you.
I just finished the game.
It was a good time.
It was a lot of fun.
And...
Finally won 1,000 wins.
Thank you!
Is this game not that long?
Oh no, it's pretty long actually.
There's...
Quite a bit of content.
Actually, it's very...
I mean, even just for extra ops, there's over a hundred.
And the main ops...
There's a lot too.
This game is very, very jam-packed with stuff.
Yeah, this is the 5th stream.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I should have mentioned that too.
Yeah, I beat...
The game...
Today.
Toki raided that and saw that.
She probably played it.
I don't think so.
Peak Metal Gear, Peak Kojima, Peak Cinema.
Yeah!
I recently finished this on PSP again.
Oh nice!
It's so fun.
Maybe I'll take a look at this after I'm done with Phantom Pain.
If you...
The story of this game is what makes Phantom Pain make sense.
Did we watch Snake play Kaz like a fiddle?
Probably.
Great content.
Thank you.
This is the most peak way to end.
Have a great night, boss.
Oh, good night.
Sorry, you're not telling me to have a great night.
I just filled that in with my own brain.
And WSF.
Ah...
Oh,
wait a second.
How do I show off the models?
Wait, where is it under again?
Is it under R&D?
Because can't I also see her underwear?
Personnel.
Where's pause?
Are you sure it's here?
First stream that I've actually watched live and it's been very funny.
Thank you!
Double tap triangle or... Okay, let me see.
Let's do...
Oh, it's only for some.
Like Chico didn't allow it.
When did this happen?
Wow!
Thank you!
What the...
Thank you, Lord!
Thank you!
Does Huey have a... Oh, what?
No, Huey doesn't.
Thank you!
Hideo Kojima!
Kojima is gone!
Kojima...
That's my girl!
This bear have one.
Chico doesn't have one.
Maybe Amanda?
Where is Amanda under?
Pause, Chico.
Or is she gone?
Technically.
Amanda!
Where are you?
Who is this?
What is TRD mean?
The boots stay on!
Wait, where is she?
Trade?
What do you mean trade?
Oh!
Sorry, I thought you meant like she was in trade.
I think maybe we...
We might have gotten rid of Amanda.
Wait!
No way!
Amanda, you're here.
Amanda, show yourself!
C...
Ask and you shall receive...
Oh my gosh!
I won!
Wait, I won the MSF top!
That's too cute!
I won it!
I won one!
The zoom in these games is extremely generous.
Wow!
Anyways guys, thank you for a piece of Walker!
And we will do Ground Zeroes sometime.
Either tomorrow or sometime next week.
Yes.
But...
From here, Metal Gear is just sad, sad, sad.
So, this is our last ounce of silly that we would have.
And...
Last, last bit of silliness.
Now it's time for sad, sad hours.
But this is a lot of fun.
And yeah!
I hope I was of decent help.
You were!
Thank you!
Don't worry about it, Sapphire.
We killed... We kicked butt.
Yeah!
Thank you.
Don't worry about it at all.
So...
Yeah!
Thank you guys.
And...
I'll see you when I see you.
Yeah!
Otsumito!
I don't know how to end this because it's like the game doesn't have like credits to us.
You know?
We already did the credits.
I wish we could just watch the...
I wish we could just watch...
Love Deterrence again.
Okay!
Otsumito!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
See you!
Itterasshai!
Bye bye!